des images de dimanche soir adil ont
désormais un classique du genre vide est
illégal car non autorisée par les
autorités
dès 14 heures les forces de l'ordre ont
convergé vers ce quartier populaire
foyalais objectif éviter que les
carnavaliers se dirigent leur fort de
france empêcher tout risque de
débordement au centre ville les
fonctionnaires de police ne sont pas là
pour empêcher aux gens de s'exprimer ils
sont là simplement pour empêcher des
actes de vandalisme comme on a connu au
mois de novembre dernier ils sont là
aussi pour empêcher ou aux gens de cassé
mais on n'a pas compris on n'a pas
compris ce qui s'est passé hier parce
que les manifestations sont interdites
les rassemblements sont interdits et
nous avons eu 200 300 personnes qui ont
défilé par par voie des réseaux sociaux
de manifester faire du carnaval donc il
est évident que c'est une défiance aux
autorités qu'elles soient politiques
préfectoral ou même policière les
carnavaliers sont rejoints par des
groupes circulant à deux roues en
provenance des quartiers avoisinants le
cortège part vers fort-de-france et
forces de l'ordre passent à l'action et
dispersent leurs idées à l'aide de gaz
lacrymogènes le syndicat police affiche
son incompréhension ce que nous
regrettons le plus dans cette affaire
c'est que les gens qui décident de
braver l'autorité comme ça il met aussi
en danger
la vie de leurs enfants parce qu'avec
des enfants mineurs ils avaient des
enfants de dix rangs 12 ans il y avait
des personnes qui avaient avec dvb donc
nous ce que nous disons c'est que que
veut-il on n'est pas en train de on
n'est pas en train de revendiquer quoi
que ce soit sur la pandémie on a un
trait de demander à à se défouler or je
pense qu'il ya d'autres choses beaucoup
plus importantes aujourd'hui à
martinique de penser au défoulement hier
soir 21h tout était rentré dans l'ordre
jusqu'à la prochaine fois l'avis des
sauvages sont devenu chose courante
depuis plusieurs semaines déjà et
services de l'état la ville de fort de
france semble bien démuni face à un tel
phénomène